well i haven't been in serious trouble
with the media for
about three days i think so it's
probably time to do something that'll
what do they come at you for
jesus i i don't know really i mean
i i expected the attention around me to
d
to dissipate three or four years ago
and for some reason it it doesn't stop
and i can't figure it out really i think
maybe it's because
the media types i mean some of them have
supported me
don't get me wrong but they can't really
figure me out because what i'm doing
isn't really political
it's psychological and i am a clinical
psychologist i've been writing these
books to help people
there's other reasons as well they have
to make everything political and i don't
quite
fit that mold and so i don't think they
know what to do with me and
they want to put you in a box yes and
then bury the box
and then burn the ground and then salt
the earth
they want you to say i'm left or i'm
right and you're like listen i'm neither
i'm watching both sides
and making my own decisions that's how i
see you i don't know
if that's true or not but i see you in a
very similar
not that i'm wearing equal footing but i
see you in the same way i see things
it's not i'm no i don't pick a team here
i'm just watching both sides and trying
to figure out where the is the
truth
well i hope that that's what i'm doing
that's how i read it
thank you i appreciate that if they're
not getting that that means
they're not smart enough to get you that
therefore they shouldn't be got
well it's it's yeah it's been a great
mystery and it's all come up again this
week so
um i don't know what to say about it
exactly
it's um stressful yes
however it is stressful um but
i mean the pro their problem with you is
that you're very articulate
and you enunciate well and they can't
handle that because they're trying to
push you in the corner to make you uh
to sweat and hopefully hope that you
fall apart and i'm like it's not a
facade guys that's really who this guy
is
you're not gonna uh make that might
actually be part of the problem
they might have been reading things or
even listening to lectures and they're
like well maybe he's got that memorized
maybe this is somewhat of a facade
i think that could be part of it i'll
get to the real thing and then when it
doesn't appear it makes them angry maybe
yeah i don't
we northern albertans are known for
enunciation skills you know you're from
northern alberta
yes i knew where you were from to be
honest i thought you were a toronto bay
no 350 miles northwest of edmonton in a
little town called fairview
i know fairview there was a gig there
back in the day
no really fairview 26 years ago i did a
show in fairview and i remember going
what the is this place
it was like there was a hockey arena
there
yes and the hotel was part of the hockey
arena
and it had no windows it literally
looked like this room was just like
cement walls i was like
am i in jail and it was freezing
yes it's freezing it's very cold there
yeah it's very cold in canada obviously
but that's
particularly cold part of canada yes i i
know exactly where you're from where
there was a comic
back in the day maybe around around 96
97 a comic named monty cohen died out
there he was
i think he was going for a run or
something and he got hit by a truck
hmm and i was okay it was all bad
because i remember i had lent him uh
these vhs tapes of i used to be a big
kiss fan when i was a kid
that's embarrassing i used to i used to
i found these really cool vhs kiss tapes
and i lent them to him and then he died
i was like
damn it how am i gonna get my kiss tapes
back
actually i listened to kiss when i was
13. i have to admit it
how old are you now 58.
oh so you got seven years on me i
thought you were younger than that
you're you're so youthful looking
that's the brown i'll be 51 this year
hmm so you're not in canada anymore you
relocated to the states
a while ago 15 years ago but
day by day i consider moving back home
every day i'm like you know what
i don't see the purpose of being here
anymore where are you located
i'm in vegas and los angeles
oh you're in vegas you live in vegas
yeah i've been there for 14 years
that's that must be
a trip i mean at first you know when i
was
when i first moved out there and i was
in my late 30s it was great you know
you're you're a young guy you got you
suddenly got money
you got no dependents you're gonna have
a blast in vegas at that time but as you
get older you're like no this is not for
me anymore
and uh and you know my kids are both in
los angeles so i have to spend some time
there to see them all the time
i think that's really the only thing
stopping me from moving back to canada
are my kids because i have two different
baby mamas because i'm an idiot
and uh one i think would let my daughter
go but the other one will not let my son
go that's
that's a different that's a different
part of on its own so
i like l.a i've been there many times
i like l.a yeah i've seen you but i
think
what's that i've seen you on joe rogan's
podcast yeah yeah yeah i
have some friends out in la that i visit
quite frequently
so um but it there are some advantages
to living in canada
i i think the advantage it being it
being canada
that's the advantage it's funny to me
when i hear all the americans go we're
not turning into a socialist country
it's socialism like it's really not that
bad guys
it's really not that bad guys you see
how your teeth are crooked and your
your spine is broken well it wouldn't be
like that in canada
because we're socialist and the
taxes are like it's like the same now i
mean
at least in canada you pay high taxes
you get something for it
you get better roads and you get health
care over here you get nothing you might
just get shot that's about it
i'm ready to move somewhere warmer i
thought texas is looking pretty nice
texas is pretty cool though i do like
texas i do uh you're not wrong michaela
so your your how has your comedy changed
and shifted over the years
i think it's become a little bit more uh
introspective i don't think the set that
i'm doing right now
is as introspective as a as the last one
was but
um it's it's a work in progress right
now i don't know
i'm trying to figure out how to uh word
this one the right way because i don't
i want to toe the line you know and i i
because when you're telling the line
somebody's bound to get offended to take
it the wrong way
but i want to make it so that if you
take it the wrong way i could show you
why you're wrong
so i'm figuring out the wording at the
moment but
you know i'm trying to cover subjects
about you know it's
we're part of you and i are part of the
generation that
i i say that i feel like my generation
is mad at the younger generation
like we look at them like they're idiots
and that they're soft and that they're
sensitive but
the problem with that is we made that
generation
that generation was inside of us and we
released it
so i'm trying to figure out the wording
behind all of this because i want to
make it
you know i want to make it that you know
you understand that i'm i recognize that
we're mad at you but i also recognize
that i can't stop myself from being mad
at you
well i think every generations tend to
think that the up-and-coming generation
is softer
absolutely we all listen mike i know my
parents thought the same thing and i
i bring that up as well you know my
every time like i said you know my dad
when he would hit me he would tell me
how much less of a beating this was than
he got
you know so i always like to go the
extra mile and make it extra goop i said
my dad tell me
you're lucky this is all you're getting
your grandfather threw a leopard at me
where'd he get a leopard it was india
they were everywhere
have you had to tone things down in
comedy because i
like there's a people well people are
all stressed out anyway because of this
whole covid situation but
um some comedians have been
have been somewhat destroyed and you
tell like you're really funny
but you you veer into
well i would say like a lot of race
jokes and you described them earlier
they're funny and maybe it's because you
cater to the people you're
you're joking about but how have you
managed one how have you managed to
i guess get away with doing that
especially with media
and yeah that's the main question well
i'm kind of the beauty for me is that
my audience is loyally my audience
so the people that are getting offended
would never have bought a ticket to see
me to begin with
so i can't cater to the to the hater i
gotta cater to the people that are gonna
that enjoy you and want to see what you
do it's like
your dad just started to change his tune
all of a sudden because he got
influenced by the people telling him he
should
watch what he says you know that would
that would make you untrue to yourself
and untrue to your people
and then you'll have literally nobody
because the haters aren't going to
accept you ever
and the people that want to hear what
you have to say you've just turned your
back on them so
i got to stay true to who i am and i
always know my intent when i'm saying
things i know that my intent is never
to offend or or hurt anybody's feelings
my intent is only to make you laugh
and if you get offended by something i
said then you've got your own personal
issues you're working with
i just happen to trigger them and make
you realize that this is a problem for
you and maybe you need to go see a
psychologist
well i think part of the reason i get
away with
offering people advice let's say is
because
i try to include myself in the group of
people to whom i'm offering advice
right i'm always thinking
of the ways that i don't live up to my
own expectations and
i think that and i think that's genuine
i don't think it's a front um
i think that you know you make
no shortage of jokes about your own
ethnic group and
you're always part you're always the bot
of your jokes
as well as the person who's telling them
and so the audience can tell that right
away it's obvious that you're not
telling jokes from a position of
superiority it's more like
well look guys you know we're all idiots
um yes we are each idiots in our own
particular ways
ethnicity included and here's some of
the foibles but
you know let's not forget that it's
universal truth that we're all fools
yeah i i think that's i mean that's
basically how i approach it because
yeah i in my head there's nobody above
and there's nobody below we're all on
the same playing field
um you know there's people you admire
and then there's
and then there's people that whatever
but to me it's all literally we're all
in the exact same playing field i talk
to
you know i talk to kings and queens and
and and world leaders then i talk to
them the exact same way i talk to my
friends
maybe a little bit more respectful but i
don't fawn over them
so to speak i'm not like yes sir oh what
can i do if i'm like oh shut the up
listen dude
um you know i i have i have some you
know i'm friends with
the king of jordan and when him and i
talk it's like two guys talking it's not
like
sir how are you how have you been have
you been pleased so
you know it's none of that it's just
like hey ab what's going on buddy you
know
it's it's really cool to have these
kinds of to be able to be privileged
enough to
to get to have the to be put in these
situations and then
it's even more of a privilege to be able
to act normal with them